I'm gonna ask y'all because you guys all
have classic bodies of work solo uh Cube
what is if you had to what is your
your magnum opus of your discography
what's your favorite
album in your discography what do you
think is the best obviously America's
Most Wanted got five mics in the swords
you got the Predator you got lethal
injection I mean I would say death
certificate that's probably the one
because it's
it's the most dynamic
um
you know I think that's a great record
uh predators are pretty good record
laugh now cry later is a good one but
death certificate is probably the cream
of the crop what about for you sure
album best album
try the best Too Short album is probably
getting it album number 10. that's my
favorite that's the that's the um we got
orange cover I was with my man I had
that [ __ ] when I was a kid production
team that had been working together for
like five albums shorty B at Banks
Peewee myself we were the core of like a
production team that made a lot of music
it was a cohesive sound it was and
uh before that I had my top seller was
life is too short that's like Classics
that's like that's the only double
Platinum I had but me when I listen to
the music and the production it's
definitely getting it that's the I was
gonna ask you because you also like over
the years short like
because you you guys have all been in
this [ __ ] since the 80s right but like
it's crazy when you listen to life is
too short and I can't imagine like
the [ __ ] you were saying on some of them
records well I used to have a technique
where um I kind of still do it but I had
a technique where before I would like
write songs I would just write down the
craziest stuff I could think of and just
like you know I guess it would be like
the shock value like a song like cuss
words had to be like at the time like
what the [ __ ] or [ __ ] Betty had to be
like people were like what is going on
songs are like really long and there's
like a lot of rapping in like there's no
hook on yeah the hook don't come for
like 48 bars you said [ __ ] he's a
true story yeah I killed her oh that's
terrible she choked on the Spiderman
died but it was like so far back before
social media and all that stuff it
didn't really get out there like that
are you saying the statute of
limitations has passed I mean it didn't
it doesn't exist there's no victim
there's no case to it there's you have
to go do some
some super forensics amount 40. what's
your best album
because you got a couple you could go
with there's a couple errors we could go
with yeah can I say can I go by the
heires yeah of course in the 90s it was
because
okay all right pick one is it in a major
way
your favorite You album come on man
that's easy no it ain't no it's not I
have got two favorites say it then can
you say two favorites I got like okay
come on man you dealing with a dude that
got more top 200 billboard
the album entries in the history of
hip-hop listen listen listen listen
listen
use your ears and listen let me ask you
foreign
his favorite E40 album is all the E40
albums give me one give me one
let me tell you the one you want me I'm
gonna tell you something
it ain't it give me two of them I'm
gonna give you two okay give me two in a
major way okay
and element of surprise oh devil album
oh yes sir them the sickest albums I
ever did and and uh and don't knock not
excluding get a report card
in the 2000s what's your favorite that
was like in a major way I mean my
favorite artwork you got some legendary
art favorite artwork was one in a major
way artwork when I was in I was you know
cooking y'all in the Gumbo Pot you know
making soup between all of us and Snoop
Dogg that's an amazing oh for sure
artwork has been amazing nah for sure
forget about the music and just the
album covers are like legendary 100